Each language has its own sound and structure,
and feels a certain way.
Italian is musical, while German is harsher.
And the same person fluent in both can seem
like they have two distinct personalities.
But can language really influence who we are?
Linguistic relativity theory suggests that
the languages we pick up and use influence
how we see the world - the perception of our
surroundings, our sense of time, our memories,
our behavior, and even our sense of self.
First, there’s our perception.
Each language has different words to describe
the things around us and these differences
change the way we perceive these things.
For example, an Italian might see objects
as male or female, while an English speaker
won’t —a phenomenon that extends to the
perception of space.
The Kuuk Thaayorre, an aboriginal tribe, does
not use left or right in their language.
Instead, they rely on cardinal directions:
North, East, South, and West.
They might say “Pass me the salt on the
South-west of the pepper”.
It's probably no coincidence that they have
supernatural navigational skills.
There is the sense of time.
Because languages are written in different
directions, people who write left to right
will perceive the sequence of events accordingly.
Speakers of Arabic and Hebrew might do so
the other way around.
In the Amele language in Papua New Guinea,
there are 3 forms of past tense: Today’s
past tense, yesterday’s, and remote past
tense.
To use the correct verb, speakers need to
pay close attention to when something has
happened — and hence may perceive the past
in greater detail.
Language also affects our Memories.
In English, if a child breaks a vase accidentally,
we may say “he broke the vase” — putting
the responsibility on the kid.
In Spanish people would say “El jarrón
se rompió” or “The vase broke” — giving
more credit to the environment — a small
difference with big consequences.
Studies show that speakers of languages like
Spanish that tend to consider these kinds
of events accidental are less likely to recall
the people involved.
In languages that emphasize an intention,
the actors are remembered more clearly.
And if things end up in court the accused
is more likely to be found guilty, if the
language used during the trial is active,
like English.
Then there is our behavior.
Languages are often associated with culture,
and with the context in which it was learned.
As a result, those who speak various languages,
access different parts of themselves.
One study on Spanish-English bilinguals showed
that people exhibit different personality
traits when switching their language.
When speaking English, subjects were more
agreeable, but when they switched to Spanish
they were more neurotic.
And finally, our sense of self.
The words we speak also influence how we feel
about ourselves.
Self-affirming language for example activates
brain areas linked to reward and self-perception
and can increase our confidence — an effect
that extends to how we perceive pain.
Bilinguals report greater levels of pain when
they speak the language to which they relate
the most.
The theory: if one language represents a bigger
part of their identity, they also perceive
the sensations inside their body with greater
intensity.
With about 7000 languages all around us, nobody
knows exactly how they affect our minds.
But they certainly frame our thoughts and
influence the way we look at the world.
In Thai for example, the word for heart, 'jai',
is woven into their language to describe a
variety of human traits.
Someone friendly is “jai dee”, literally
a good heart.
Someone that’s patient is “jai yen”
a "cool heart " and someone generous, is “jai
gwang” a "big heart”.
As Benjamin Lee Whorf, the linguist behind
the theory wrote: "Language is not merely
a reproducing instrument for voicing ideas
but rather is itself the shaper of ideas,
the program and guide for the individual's
mental activity."
So, if you ever learn a new language, remember:
you're not just learning new words.
You're opening your mind to a new way of seeing
and interacting with the world.
What do you think?
Do you speak more than one language?
And if so, do you feel like your behavior
changes when you switch between them?
Tell us your thoughts and experiences
in
the comments below!
This video was brought to you by wiseone.io
Wiseone is an all-in-one browser extension
that offers a new way of reading
and exploring information online.
It consists of 5 useful features:
Focus helps you understand
complex concepts and words.
Cross-check helps you access
factual and reliable sources reporting on
the same subject to get diverse perspectives.
Ask Anything simplifies complex information into
understandable and sourced answers from the web.
Summarize helps you read more efficiently
without losing information by providing
key takeaways to remember.
And Explore provides articles
and videos from diverse sources to
deepen your understanding of a topic.
WiseOne is free and available in different
languages and also works on PDFs!
All of this makes Wiseone an
excellent tool for learning
new things, developing your critical
thinking, and getting answers to your
most complex questions. To install
Wiseone, visit https://wiseone.io/,
click the "Add on Chrome" button, and install
the extension. That's it! Try it now! Wiseone.io
If you found this helpful, check out our other
videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work, join us on
patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional contents,
visit sproutsschools.com